c'est toujours la même chose chaque fois
que nous nous réunissons monsieur du
snob arrive bon dernier
enfin françois de teint patiente pas
n'est pas encore pour sur l'heure du
rendez-vous et dans cinq secondes 4 3 2
une bonjour mes très chers amis bonjour
ne sait ni snob services comme notre
cher ami permettez moi vous baiser la
main avec joie vc 10 9
je l'étais point retard la nanon
l'exactitude parfait ah vous êtes arrivé
à la seconde près à l'heure de notre
rendement
ah si vous étiez employé à la poste mon
chef serait ravi c'est vrai il dit
toujours linceul heures avant l'heure
c'est pas l'heure
après leur cellule oui oui pour ma part
mon serré mais je préfère considérer que
l'exactitude et la politesse des rois
ob comme vous voudrez bébé moi je
préfère là je crois que faire là la
phrase de mon chef surtout plus
rigolotes
d'ailleurs si mademoiselle messieurs je
vous ai réunis pour un sujet de la plus
haute importance et qui nous concerne
tous
j'ai dû me prévenir j'aurais pris pour
tous la meilleure décision
mais vous oubliez le bon sens populaire
v non je n'oublie rien devant jérémy je
n'oublie rien seul membre comme c'est
moi qui trouve toujours les meilleures
décisions j'aurais pu vous habitez un
déplacement inutile
bon puisque nous sommes tous là et bien
voilà vous n'avez pas été sans remarquer
depuis quelques temps que casimir est de
moins en moins dynamique
on a l'impression qu'il se traîne sans
était un courage c'est pourquoi je vous
ai réunis
que faut-il faire julie s'il te plaît de
nous tourner opinion et bien moi je
pense qu'il faudra peut-être le métro
régime lui interdire les friandises le
gloubiboulga ils en mangent beaucoup
trop régime
c'est possible et vous monsieur du ce
noble qu'en pensez vous et bien comme je
l'avais laissé prévoir
j'ai trouvé la meilleure solution bravo
dit vite
nous devrions confier notre ami casimir
un excellent ami à moi qui s'appelle
jacques roseau j'ai un très bon cours de
maintien car comme disait mon grand père
alexandre 19 mai sana in corpore sano
j'ai rien compris que ça veut dire c'est
du latin et ça veut dire un esprit sain
dans un corps sain
c'est ça bellouti je pense qu'un peu de
l'éducation raffiné lui fera le plus
grand bien
oui alors jacques zoo voilà une
intéressante proposition et vous facteur
vraiment à moi je crois que je suis bien
placé pour donner mon opinion un oui
puisque je suis presque aussi fort aussi
gros que casimir donc mon opinion c'est
qu'il faut faire du sport
moi même je n'en fais pas assez bon
alors casimir devra faire du sport devra
moins manger il se trouvera bien plus
fort avec plus de muscles et en pleine
forme alors régir jacques those faire du
sport est bien en ce qui me concerne
c'est la proposition de notre facteur
qui me semble être la meilleure
la raison soit moi je me range à son
avis aussi je ne peux que regretter une
fois de plus que ma génial suggestion
n'est pas emporter vos suffrages
depuis lors voilà ce que je vous propose
je vais aller chez monsieur le sprint le
marchand d'articles de sport pour voir
ce que l'on pourrait faire faire à
casimir évidemment je vous tiendrais
tous au courant très bien
la séance est levée ah ah
[Musique]
kampala pas d'amis daisy mais qu'est ce
que c'est
casimir nos vieux ça ne peut plus durer
mais enfin tu te plus en plus mal à sion
nous avons décidé qu'il fallait que je
fasse du sport pour retrouver la grande
forme
bon je veux qu'ils me françois mais quel
sport tu vas voir ce triste et j'ai
apporté ici qu'un accessoire qui
représentent chacun un sport les enfants
vont expliquer de quel sport il s'agit
ensuite de choisir à celui qui te plaît
le plus non mais c'est une très bonne
idée ça à françois n'est ce pas alors
les enfants que vous allez expliquer à
gaz inerte quels sont les sports que
l'on peut pratiquer avec chacun de ces
objets d'accord et aussi chez recherché
comme un saut par ce ballon
c'est un ballon c'est un ballon c'est un
ballon de rugby très bien le rugby pont
c'est une raquette une raquette 2 c'est
une raquette de tennis mon volant aussi
comme oui non pas exactement ça ne
m'inquiète pour la long ça un ballon de
foot de football encore un ballon
à je ne sais pas tu saint malo 2 à
ballon de handball
casimir du poil chercher un petit peu on
va laisser à sa joie avec les maires à
[Musique]
ce ne sont pas des chaussures de tennis
c'est pas des chaussures de football ce
sont des chaussures à pointes pour faire
de la course à pied je sers à quoi les
points
les poèmes servent à s'accrocher dans le
sud dans le sol pour aller plus vite car
oui tiens ça qu'est ce que c'est que ça
non c'est pas pour faire le jardin c'est
pas un outil de jardinage que nous
savons c'est à biolay c'est un piolet
pour les alpinistes dans la montagne
oui on en mange des rochers et games
accroche toi quand il se sert de ça pour
faire des petites marches pour poser les
pieds en suite des opérations
qu'est ce que c'est fort
très bientôt menacé des sports serge
bloch ce week-end lire connais très bien
ce sport il a déjà sa dîme extérieur a
contribué du snob et ma famille comme
une raquette de ping pong pas de
problème tout le monde connaît ça qu'est
ce que ça serait plus difficile pour
jouer à quoi c'est une crosse de hockey
sur glace
voilà un air de 7 mardi pour pousser le
palet qui est ainsi l'état pendant
quelques mois ça ressemble un petit peu
c'est pas une canne c'est une crosse et
cette fois c'est une crosse de chercher
chez vous une crosse de du hockey sur
gazon
voilà c'est un casque de motard alors
casimir
quel est l'objet qui te convient pas
écoute c'est très difficile parce que
tous ces sports sont très intéressants
mais fatigante oui oui c'est vrai que
désigne en es tu comptes tu faire
raconte france je crois que je je vais
prendre quelques jours pour réfléchir
tranquillement au sport que je vais
choisir
mais alors qu'ils imitent tu ne veux
aucun des objets que vent monsieur les
sprints n'ont aucun de tous ceux qui
sont là non non non mais j'ai vu chez
lui un tracas très bel objet ah oui et
lequel s offre en soit il s'agit d'une
magnifique magnifique chaise longue
casimir
[Musique]